there's emerging research to suggest
that the virtual particles that pop in
and out of existence are
connected they're they're entangled
they're Quantum entangled awesome and if
we think of that entanglement as with
their connectivity being provided by
many
wormholes right it may be that these
mini
wormholes is the literal fabric of
SpaceTime
[Music]
itself this is Star Talk Cosmic query's
Edition fan favorite Neil degrass Tyson
here your personal astrophysicist Chuck
Nice of course is yes right across the
way that's right all right Chuck you're
you're dialing in from your hometown of
where where you live in Hoboken I'm in
Hoboken New Jersey right here I'm the
I'm the Sarah Palin of New York I can
see it from my
house okay you can see New York I can
see New York from my house and I
literally can see New York from my house
so I call myself the Sarah Palin of of
of New York City you know there you have
it we we got Cosmic quaries today yes we
and it's it's a grab bag ah so I don't
know and I haven't seen the questions
yet so if you get have question I can't
answer I'll just say I can't answer it
well that's not GNA
happen
stop
oh you going you going to answer
something I will atone for if I don't
know I want to still say something we
gonna answer something it may not be the
answer that we want but you gonna get an
answer so all right yeah all right let's
do it this is Corey Allen and Corey
Allen says or is it Alan Corey Alan
because it's just Al
N I think Cory's playing with my head
okay uh he says hey
two it's two people a Cory and an allen
yes could be two
people hailing here from the Twin Cities
Minnesota uh what would a wormhole
actually look like would you just see
through it to the other side would it be
completely void of light would it be
extremely bright would love to get your
take and love love love the show there
you go oh thank you thank you so let's
back up a little so in the 1960s when we
were more fully exploring the
mathematics of SpaceTime and you get a
black hole out of that it turns out
there's another solution that would come
out of the equations that was the
mathematical opposite of a black hole
and so we would call that a white hole
that let me that that's that
sounds I was going to say I thought
black hole sounded racist but white hole
that's that's just crazy okay
so all right so a white hole would be
the opposite so black hole absorbs
everything nothing comes out a white
hole everything only comes out so one
people hypothesize if these are two
solutions in the equations maybe they're
connected maybe a black hole connects to
a white hole because where is it going
if it's going in a black hole in a white
hole where's it coming from if it's
coming out so if they're connected what
might connect them it's some called a
wormhole all right so some of the
earliest ideas about wormholes started
that way in modern times however we can
make on paper we can make worm holes on
paper that don't require a black hole or
a white hole for them to exist so in
order to make a a a wormhole you're
prying open the fabric of space and time
and when when you do that you're doing
the opposite of what gravity would
normally do which would compress it back
so to pry it open you can do this
mathematically but you you need a
substance that would pry it open you
need some anti-gravity magic substance
that will do this and when you do that
then you got to pack it right so that it
priz open the hole and it would be a
hole between where you are in some other
place in SpaceTime right okay
and because it's a threedimensional hole
a brain doesn't has a hard time
conceiving of dimensional holes you
think of a hole it's like a circle and
you jump in and fall through right okay
like a utility hole cover you fall
through this is a hole no matter which
direction you approach it right that's
awesome so that's a little weird that's
great that's awesome right right you go
around the side it's the same hole
coming through right right right right
right so if you Pro Pride a hole to some
other space and time then every direct
as far as I can tell every Direction you
look at it would get would see exactly
the same thing because it's the same
hole that you're looking through right
and and they try to represent this in
Rick and Morty and in who's the dude
that does this in with his fingers the
magic strange wand Doctor Strange so
doct strange uses magic to open up a
hole through the SpaceTime Continuum but
Rick uses actual science I just want to
make that important distinction between
the two
yeah the guy with trash cans for engines
on his spaceship is using actual science
yeah I'm just saying I'm just I don't
want to you know overstate the obvious
but okay so so yeah it would be quite
fascinating to accomplish this and we
say that it's through SpaceTime not just
through space right because for example
Superman when he was uh launched from
his home planet Planet just before it
was destroyed he was launched um Moses
style right basically in some kind of a
basket right and then he arrives on
Earth and he's the same age right he's
still right now you know this because
babies's you know two months or one you
know baby's age you know it okay it's
the same baby so it travel this vast
distance basically
instantly whereas Where We Are is not
available to Krypton in that same time
frame because it takes light time to get
there so it beat the light beam to get
here okay and in fact in In Action
Comics what's the number is that Action
Comics yeah here it is Action Comics
number wow 14 14 okay nice Action Comics
number 14 sweet uh you know about this
you don't know about this comic
no you don't know about this one no I I
see Superman's on there yeah Superman's
it's a Superman comic you didn't know
about this chck how could you not know
about this how could let me show you the
page let me
see dude that's insane that's well first
of all anybody who's listening right now
if you're listening and you're not
watching then uh it is actual cartoon
depiction
of Neil degrass Tyson standing with
Superman and you know for a fact that
it's Neil and no no other black man on
Earth because he is wearing the Neil
degrass Tyson vest with the stars on it
and and the moons and the plan moons and
the planets that's cool so here here's
the thing so when I say I've met
Superman people say oh which Superman
did you meet so I metad Superman yeah
well which I metad Superman okay exactly
there it is so In Action Comics 14 a
Superman comes to the Hayden planetarium
to observe the destruction of Krypton
that's amazing the light from which was
only just then reaching earth right yet
he got here right after birth so he beat
the light beam that's all I'm saying so
he the only way he could have come here
is via a wormhole by the way if he
traveled at the speed of light he would
not age okay because Einstein's equation
stipulated that right however he would
have arrived with the light cone right
okay with the light beam right and then
he would not be old enough to have seen
his home planet destroyed right so so I
was happy to contribute to the Superman
cannon that way and identified what star
in the night sky would be Krypton where
you'd find Krypton and it was a red
dwarf star that sort of thing the star
was in the constellation corvis a
southern hemisphere constellation and
corvis is a crow and
smallville's mascot is a crow wow now is
that by is that by Design
or no no they didn't have they hadn't
picked they don't they didn't have a
place I gave them the place oh you gave
I told them where Krypton yes oh sweet I
said I said the only way this can happen
is if Superman arrived via Wormhole via
Wormhole I told this to the to the
writers right I told this to them that's
really cool oh we didn't know that oh
okay is that what you're doing is that
what you're doing when you're standing
next to Superman are you Neel splaining
to
him are you
neeling the fact that he had to come
here through a through a wormhole yeah
well what what he might not have known
because he was a baby I'm just saying
that's so great a wormhole would be a
fascinating to look at and to travel
through and to go back and forth oh by
the way I was on a the trucker channel
on SiriusXM this past weekend okay
there's a trucker Channel well you
really take this reaching out to people
things seriously don't
you
Damn Channel you trying to yeah trucker
Channel you trying to get to
everybody truckers want to learn
something too truckers so so we were
having fun with the fact that the day
will come if we in discover this
mysterious substance that's the opposite
of gravity to pry open wormholes if
wormholes become ubiquitous then you
would not need trucks you would just
open a wormhole from where you are to
where the thing has to be and pass it
through you wouldn't need roads you
wouldn't need trucks you wouldn't need
drivers the back of your refrigerator
would connect to the grocery the grocery
would look through oh your milk is going
bad let me swap that out you need
another dozen eggs close up the back and
you're done and thank you we appreciate
having Neil grass Tyson on the trucker
Channel that'll be all that'll be all
for today on the trucker CH that Neil
just destroyed along with
Superman wait and and then the phone
rings five minutes later uh this is the
head of the Teamsters Union
exactly no so we we joked they were they
he was good about it he said um we
should get ready for the future where
there's picket line saying truckers
against wormholes yes see
that's the picket sign the Millennium
right that's great that's great that's
very cool man it is that's more than our
fellow wanted to know about wormholes
right there oh yeah all right but there
you go at least you know it's going to
be a hole that no matter where you are
from every direction you're looking into
that hole so that's kind of cool
yeah we spent a lot of time on that
question okay what else you got it was
fun mhm uh this is cherri's
Jubilee who
says um
hello Dr Tyson what's up Chuck Autumn
Rose here from York
Pennsylvania um my first Guru uh Jay
lahan started his journey in Rel in
religion after his Mastery of
astrophysics I had my own religious
epiphanies during my studies of geology
and botney have you ever had a moment in
your studies that made you feel like you
were having a religious
experience no and thank you for your
question no no I base that on the fact
that I've had people who've had
religious experiences describe them to
me right and I can say I've never had
them I I can say that pure and simple
based on the accounts that I have heard
okay now I grew up with a friend who was
very religious later in his life born
again and actually Jehovah's Witness and
difference he's a witness as they say
they don't say Jehovah anymore can I get
a
witness
okay yes okay in science of course in
science eyewitness is the lowest form of
evidence you can bring to the table just
given how rif it is with with error and
misinterpretation what they should what
they should s what they should instead
say I need
data rather I need a witness can I get
some
data
yes never once in a
while you got to look up and you got to
trust the data but is your data corrupt
is your data corrupt that's what you
have to figure
out that's the
preacher the preaching
scientist I'm talking empirical
evidence that's a whole TV series right
there right yes
uh um so now I forgot where what I was
talking
about yeah so so I've we we've talked
about science and religion like our
whole lives my friend and I and we I
would describe to him I would go to a
Mountaintop to
observe the universe and back in the day
it was an ordeal I mean you take trains
planes automobiles you would go you
would invert to live nocturnally you
would uh set up the telescope your
Sunset was the beginning of your day
when it was near the end of everyone
else's day and then it's you the
telescope and the
cosmos in the Eerie Silence of the
night but there's the den of the
electronics driving the telescope
juxtaposed with it and I would look up
and I would feel very deeply connected
to the cosmos he was quick to say that's
like a religious experience and so I
said okay except I wasn't thinking God I
was thinking this is a magnificent
glorious Universe yes but you were I
have the privilege studying you you
beheld that scene with awe you were in
awe of the universe and of and I started
using all the same words the awe and the
majesty and I was humbled in its
presence I was uh I wasn't prostrate in
its presence but I was humbled so
there's a lot of overlapping vocabulary
yeah but the when I've heard people say
they were brought to tears or they they
gave in that moment they gave themselves
to their uh to their religious figures
whoever that might have been right and
so i' I've never it's never been that
now here's what I found that people with
religious experiences typically there's
something they experience that they
cannot explain right that's normally the
case that's normally the case correct of
of any kind okay an apparition or this
or that and the other right so I have
seen
things that if I did not
know astrophysics physics uh geology
atmospheric sciences and just basically
the laws of physics I probably would
have rapidly called the police
department to try to get somebody to
investigate what I was looking at or I
would be on my knees uh in awe wondering
what what mysterious mythical forces
were operating
so so I don't know whether my knowledge
of what is possible in this universe has
precluded me from having some religious
experiences that others might have okay
right I think I think rational
investigation could kill pretty much any
religious
experience it I think a r a rational
questioning of what's going on in the
moment would would kind of in the moment
would kind of squ me tools with methods
with methods and tools to investigate
right right you know tools to make the
measurements so here's one here's one uh
uh Seth mcfarling okay a potty mouth
Seth mcfarling that's right who's
actually highly scientifically literate
okay and there's a lot of evidence for
that if you've seen Family Guy there's a
lot of science references in it yeah
right uh he's also a fan of Star Trek
and he's had the Star Trek crew as cast
members in the cartoon also he was
co-executive producer of Cosmos okay
yeah it's because of him that we brought
it to Fox that got the distribution far
greater than anything it would have
gotten on PBS anyhow
okay uh he's out late one night he lives
in Boston at the at the time he's out
late one
night and he wakes up in the morning and
he might be hung over I don't know or
did whatever and he missed his
airplane that was the airplane from
Boston that flew into the the tow CER
wow yes damn that morning he missed his
airplane everybody asked him to did you
feel closer to God did God you feel like
you were protected and he says no
because many a morning I have been hung
over and missed the I was gonna say okay
in that case my new God would be Jack
Daniels that's my new God who do you
worship I Johnny Walker Johnny Walker
black I don't know saved my life he
saved my life I'm telling you right now
turn my life
around right so so Seth MC Farley is IR
rational
a person who approaches life with
rational uh interpretations of what goes
on around him so uh and anyhow what does
that say for everyone else who died what
well God didn't save them I mean you're
stuck with the
moral conundrum of the people who did
die versus those who didn't so anyhow so
my answer is just no look at that that's
I mean listen that's maybe such such a
day will come and oh by the way was it
Hume there was a philosopher
commenting on Miracles and I'm going to
mangle the quote but he said something
like
Miracles are so
unlikely bordering on Impossible that if
you do
encounter something that you cannot
explain not only from your own base of
knowledge but is unexplainable given any
base of knowledge yet acquired on
Earth it's more likely that you simply
discovered a new law of
physics than that there is a Divine
miracle that was performed in front of
you right so they the no I mangled that
that reasoning but it's that what I said
is is the bulk of what he was getting at
and I don't even remember if it was Hume
I think it was Hume but philosophers
have thought this through and so yeah
there are new laws of physics that are
doing weird things and do you do you
pray to God or do you say no no there's
phenomena that you've never experienced
do you pray to God for it or do you
investigate it and find out You' just
made a scientific discovery so this
that's the interesting Frontier of this
whole exercise this science religion
exercise as you go forward I mean and
then there are certain things that are
just a violation of the laws of physics
like Jesus walking on water there's no
way around that either he walked on
water and that's a miracle or there's
something else going on whether it's the
testimony is incorrect behind he he was
he was behind water skis right that that
could have been it skiing on his
feet that'd be so funny bare for water
no there no there are people who are
trying like for example there's a Jesus
spider there's a spider or Jesus Lizard
Jesus lizard that can walk on water yes
I've seen that it runs they call the
Jesus Lizard but the Jesus Lizard is
walking on water because of surface
tension plus it's propelling itself so
that part of the effort gets it back out
of a little bit of water that it sunk
into plus he doesn't weigh very much so
I would say that's an insult to Jesus
because the lizard is using laws of
physics to do it right whereas Jesus had
to violate the laws of physics correct
in order for that to be the Mir to be
the mirle descri right yeah correct
correct either that or he had really
cool sandals just awesome
sandals styrofoam sand styrofoam
sand
okay
so so so does the person what's the
person's name does he or she who was it
that asked the question this this was uh
Autumn Rose from York PA oh Autumn yeah
so does autumn actually describe her
experience that that that would have
been more fun to hear what that
experience was but I'll tell you
something in my book Letters from an
astrophysicist there's an entire chapter
of me communicating with people who had
religious experiences or deep thoughts
at the intersection between religion and
and science there's a whole chapter on
that that's and one of the people who
wrote in is a niece of mine a second
cousin niece however that works or or
second cousin once removed what however
that works who her father died she went
to she went to identify the body in the
funeral parlor and had an entire
conversation with him
so I mean I'm going to say that he
wasn't dead if that happened and
maybe but but the man is flat out on on
the slab so she knowing she has a cousin
who's an astrophysicist says Neil what
do you think happened and I
said either you had an acoustic
hallucination right normally we think of
hallucinations as sight but any of any
any of your senses can be hallucinated
right you get the feeling that someone
is touching you right you can get the
you can taste something that really
isn't there there a lot of things that
can happen you can have an acoustic so
either it was an acoustic
hallucination or he was actually
communicating with you from the other
side so what I told her was next time
don't have the perfunctory conversation
you did oh Dad are you how are you oh
I'm fine um is everything okay yes and
how are you no no this is if if this is
actually happening it's not a
hallucination do not lose the
opportunity say and I gave a list of
questions I said Dad where are you right
that's are you wearing clothes right
okay uh is Mom there right how old are
the two of you right are you in your 30s
or 20s at your prime or you old and
shriveled and near dead after your half
stroke that you had a year ago okay ask
qu do you eat where do you get your food
right is there a barbecue just ask stuff
that and then you get try to get
meaningful answers from the other side
yeah see I'm skipping all that I'm like
Hey Dad uh listen uh I miss you already
but put Jesus on the phone put Jesus on
right
now talk to the man himself I need to
talk to Jesus right now okay you put
Jesus on this phone okay I'll see you
now that I'm talking to you I know I'm
going to see you later later so let's
get to what we need to get to put Jesus
on the
phone so just when you have these
experiences since we want to know more
about them of course try to try to try
to get a a a checklist of things you
might say or do when that's happening in
fact the people who say they are dying
in their hospital bed and they lift up
and they see themselves they look back
on themselves from that's a very common
experience very common so you got the
experiment for that okay we got the
experiment you set up a ledge above the
bed okay okay these are people who who
were had near-death experiences right
they saw themselves and then they went
back so you set a ledge up above the bed
and then you write something a simple
saying like roses are red or the sky is
blue okay you put that on top don't tell
the person who was
dying when they say they went up and saw
themselves they would see this thing
that you wrote and get them to tell you
what it said oh that's rough that would
be evidence that's what I'm saying that
would be evidence that they actually
came up they came out they were looking
down physically on their own body yes
yes exactly on own body in the bed
that's right so there there experiments
you can do and by the way there's a
history of this did you know that uh
late 1890s was it
19 at the turn of the century uh vham
runin you you realize he discovered
x-rays we call them x-rays in Germany
he's German they call them ruten Rays
okay as you'd expect right okay they see
through your body what people were doing
back then was oh my gosh if it can see
through the body maybe if I x-ray you
the moment of your death I will see the
soul rise up out of your Corporal
existence so they did these experiments
I mean why not yeah got a new the person
already dying they don't have to worry
about the radiation that's for
sure yeah up the dose up turn it up to
11 guys turn it up to
[Laughter]
11 so but no they didn't say anything
coming out of the body no so there it is
all right hey so thanks for that
question all right this is mahi and Mahi
says hi this is Muhammad from Columbus
Ohio I wanted to know if it is possible
to get to absolutely nothing and I mean
like eliminating every atom so
we forget more than that let's go down
to it if you can blow apart every atom
but then you got particles because
that's what Adam are made of but then
you blow apart all the particles but
then you got the bits that made up to
particles is it at what point can we get
to nothing like literally
nothing okay so in a book published just
months ago called to infinity and beyond
okay which I co-authored with our senior
producer Lindsay
nicker all right uh there's a whole
conversation about the the the search
for nothingness okay and because there
was a day when air is nothing right if
there's something there I wouldn't be
able to see you so clearly air is
nothing then you learn no air is not
nothing all right they're like molecules
what's a molecule we have to like figure
all this out this is the search for our
understanding of our place in the
universe reaching what at one time felt
like Infinity then you get there and
then there's like more Infinities Beyond
so so let's remove all the molecules and
what's left well there's space between
the molecules all right uh uh
well is there nothing between the
molecules well no because quantum
physics tells us that even where there
is
nothing there are
fluctuations that introduce what we call
virtual particles you can Google them
virtual particles they pop in and out of
existence in the
vacuum in the vacuum right okay so so
they their par particle anti particle
pairs they pop into existence and then
they recombine and there is an energy
associated with this field and we're
thinking it might be the dark energy
that everyone has been talking about but
it's it's called the vacuum energy of
the universe wow you cannot Escape that
by everything we know about all the laws
of physics it is inescapable that's
amazing wait wait wait so now let's get
deep are you seated you ready get deep
okay right let's do it let's say you
could suspend the laws of quantum
physics and not even have any particles
there any virtual particles there okay
here's a question for you if the laws of
physics still
apply does that area of nothingness
contain
nothing so we we're not accounting for
virtual
we're just looking at the nothing that's
fine just just just look at looking at
the nothing right if
if laws of physics still apply in that
nothing is there nothing there so but
how could the laws of physics apply if
there is absolutely nothing there they
have to apply to
something well they could apply to the
fabric of SpaceTime and by the way
recently told to me by my friend and
colleague Brian Green up at Columbia
right that there's emerging research to
suggest that the virtual particles that
pop in and out of existence are
connected they're they're entangled
they're Quantum entangled awesome and if
we think of that entanglement as with
their connectivity being provided by
many
wormholes right it may be that these
mini
wormholes is the literal fabric of
SpaceTime itself because it's happening
everywhere where you don't otherwise
have particles so that would be the
substrate on which all particles and
energies unfold damn so if these if
these Quantum entangle virtual particles
if there's the Wormhole that connects
them is the fabric then there it it it's
meaningless to then think of empty space
without it because there is no there
can't be there is no such thing as empty
space because the space is granted in
existence because of it exactly that's
correct right there that blew my mind
I'm having lunch with Brian Green that
blew my mind that's that's an insane
thought and I hope I recounted it
accurately I think we might get it get
Brian back on and and get yeah that's
that's incredible though I mean just to
think about that that's incredible yeah
wow okay well there you go CP more there
you go Mahi thanks that was a great
question and the answer is yeah no so um
okay
okay okay
okay this is Mike Parker hi Dr Tyson
hello Chuck Nice Mike Parker here from
Richmond Virginia do you think I was
just there I was just in Richmond
Virginia I was just there visiting their
Fair Town very nice he says do you think
AI has the ability in the near future to
make a major
scientific discovery ah if so what area
do you foresee the AI having the
greatest influence so we're training AI
what happens when it looks at data and
then says I'm just gonna come up with my
own
finding so okay so first of all that's
been happening in my field for decades
so let's just nip that in the bud right
here okay every bit of power the
computer brings us we say bring it on
and we have the computer do stuff faster
better than we ever could uh so for
example we had the
Ai and with um machine learning AI learn
how we extract the sign the signal of
planets orbiting other stars from the
data
okay right because what there's
something called a Transit method where
right if you happen to see the the star
system Edge on then the planet could
pass in front of the star gently
blocking out the light of the star and
then the light of the star recovers from
that because it's just it's just blotted
out briefly and then you wait long
enough and you watch it repeat you say
got a planet on our hands okay so this
is very hard to find because the planet
doesn't dim the Star by very much
there's a lot of noisy data we did the
best we could we trained
AI to do this we set it Loose onto the
data it found another 51 planets that we
could not have otherwise found wow so um
so AI is most excellent in that way okay
right where I'm an AI skeptic but I'm
happy to be proved wrong one day okay is
whether AI will come up with a new
idea right a new idea now big AI fans
are certain will get there but I'm not
okay for example Chuck let's say we
uploaded your brain into the internet
and it's now it's powered by AI all
right be the end of world now you go to
the
Bahamas are you goingon to be a super
villain that's the end of the world
baby so now you go to the Bahamas and
you meet someone new and that you make
good friends and you discover a new kind
of mollusk on the on the seashore okay
then and then you write a letter to a
colleague of yours who's an expert in m
is is this a new M yes that's a new
species we shall call it uh Lord Chuck
nium okay uh or or no that would be an
element on the periodic table chuck
niid whatever they have ways that they
specify names okay um and it turns out
that new
shell opens up a whole new understanding
of
shellfish okay or or or mollusks let's
say I'm making this up but just imagine
this he I would know nothing about it
because it only knows what's on the
internet and you sent a paper letter
handwritten to your colleague
oh right you discovered a whole new
branch of the tree of life and AI has no
idea it even existed and it never will
until you put it on the internet and AI
can't make that new friend you just made
okay that's right AI knows nothing about
that relationship because you didn't put
it on Instagram okay so that's very cool
in fact I think the only way to keep AI
in check so that it doesn't become our
overlords is to do do we don't put
on the internet yeah that's all you got
to do yeah all we need is pen and paper
people that's all we
need it's like Millennials all you have
to do is write something in cursive they
have no idea what it is that you're
talking
about what's out a squigle that'll get
the squigle why is it all Squigly I
don't understand
writing and code secret code for the
next World
[Music]
War so so anyhow so I I don't see them
now okay uh AI found a new strategy when
playing the game go that that's that uh
that territorial board game right that
was it's common and and very popular in
the Far East China especially
uh but many people play it and uh I I it
found a
new strategic way where it can win and
it's something that no one had thought
of before okay but it's still started
with this game that we
invented yeah okay and and honestly you
would have to it's just at that point
running a bunch of simulations and
making associative comparisons so it's
it's really the rules that we create the
rules that you created right now what
would what would impress me is if it
took the game go and created an entirely
new game and said here's the game I
created that would be amazing that's
that and if we all and and it knows what
we like about playing board games and
then it becomes the most popular game
the world right that that yeah by the
way I'm sure you know what else I wanted
to do right now Milton Bradley is like
get me AI
on the phone right now get a on the
phone I'm sorry Dave I can't do
that so uh so we'll see we'll see how AI
shakes said I want you to know and the
world to know then in my field we we use
AI at any turn we can all right very to
help us interpret analyze and obtain
data especially given the volume of data
that comes about there's no way we'd be
able to do it otherwise and there
different levels of AI there's the AI
that scares everybody which which is uh
uh AGI uh uh artificial general
intelligence where it just learns
anything at all at all times and can do
anything cook your coffee and solve your
calculus homework and write your turn
paper right right and like okay we'll
see okay yeah I mean there you go um
however we learned from our friend meio
kako the last time we had him on the
show that the true potential of AI will
be realized when we have a quantum
computer oh yes very good point right
he's all into the Quant as am I I I I'm
I'm I'm delighted and terrified by what
it will be able to compute for us yeah
yeah it's a it's a new world a new world
order I would even say right yeah wow
that's that's crazy all right here's our
uh our question from I be our last
question that's all we have time for
last question go well Charles you get
the last word Charles he says hey Neil
hey Chuck Charles here from Houston
Texas both of you guys Planet Houston
Planet Houston uh we have a problem he
says you guys are both my heroes but you
know you gotta know why I call it plan
you have to know why I call it Planet
Houston no I don't do you know why no
okay in the first Superman
movie okay okay uh or is it no second
Superman movie the second one where the
criminals come back out of The Phantom
Zone which is a two to dimensional
prison floating through space one of The
Phantom Zone got got got broken by a
nuclear explosion that Superman cast
into space to save Earth because
terrorists were going to blow up the
Eiffel Tower and so he takes it throws
it into space the blast wave which you
can't have in the vacuum of space but
it's a cartoon it's a movie uh uh it
shatters The Phantom Zone re-releasing
these three criminals there's Zod and
the two others okay
there's a meme with me um uh I'm I'm
just in sequence to him right so I'm
before Zod and Zod is after me so it's
Neil before Z it's a meme someone cooked
up you know 10 years ago when memes were
in their infancy they were
innocent okay so uh they come to the
Moon that they get closer to the our sun
which is a yellow sun which gives them
Powers okay they get to the moon and
they see astronauts
there okay and they and the astronauts
are looking through their spacit and
they just see these people but they're
like Superman type people but they don't
need space suit suits right they're
space suits and he asked them what
planet is this and the astronaut said
Houston Houston and he said oh this is
planet
Houston
Planet he thought the guy was answering
his question but he was just radioing
back to Houston that we have a problem
on the moon right so that's why I say
Planet Houston also of course Houston is
the very first word ever spoken in
comments from the Moon right actually
the very first word is contact but uh
contact light but those weren't comments
yet those were Diagnostics then when
they landed Houston comma Tranquility
base here comma the eagle has landed
there it is there you go okay so uh he
says you guys are my hero my 2-year-old
daughter is obsessed with the solar
system now in the age of social media
and constant distractions despite having
all the knowledge of our species in our
pockets what do you think is the best
strategy to Foster the love of Science
and curiosity in a young person
oh there you go nice what a nice
question yeah get out of her get out of
her way oh wow look at that H yeah why
you gota be why you gotta be so hard on
the
guy he was just asking a question about
his daughter man like get out of her way
that's what you can
do you're lousy dad
Charles we spend the first years of
their life teaching them to walk and
talk and then we spend the rest of the
life telling them to shut up and sit
down look at that right we so children
are born curious get out of their way
that Curiosity will be maintained until
the day arrives when you squash it
wow okay and so I'll give you an example
we've all had toddlers or younger they
you know they discover the pots and pans
in the cabinet right and pots and pans
are usually low they're not high up so
they drag them out onto the ground and
they start banging on it with the wooden
spoon and the and the aluminum Ladle and
the steel spoon and what do you say as a
parent um cut out cut out their racket
cook me something that's what I said
while you're there while you down
there do do something practical so
banging away and you can say stop the
Racket and you're getting the dishes
dirty right and you you have squashed an
entire experim in
Acoustics right right and that's what
they're are they're doing Sonic
experiments yep correct and so children
yes they make a mess of things but you
didn't have children you didn't have
your kids so that you maintain a neat
house no I had them as an uh basically a
retirement in um plan
that's that's why what your kids my kids
I'm like well I got three I got I got
hopes for maybe one of them you
know I got three but I got say which one
got hope for
one so so anyhow just watch what they do
if they reach for a an egg that you
haven't cracked yet to make an omelet
that just can just barely reach the
counter surface what do you typically
say at that point no no
no no yeah no no put the egg down you
might break it when you could let the
kid have the egg and you know it's going
to break but then they're going to see
what's inside the egg and there's like
the albumin and the yolk and you then
you tell them that might have been a
chicken right that that'll freak them
out right there and then they and then
they become vegan and that's how you
make a
vegan that's how you make a
vegan so that could have been a chicken
plus they learn that something could be
hard yet fragile right not many things
in a child's life are hard practically
anything that's hard is is rugged right
but an egg is hard yet fragile so that's
a new kind of concept for kids and you
learn it might have been a a a chicken
then you could take the clear liquid
heat it and it turns white right there's
a color change from transparent to White
oh my gosh all of these are lessons that
would have cost you 50 cents how much
the egg a dozen eggs cost
these days somewhere between yeah yeah I
mean they the price went up like they
can be $6 a dozen or something between
three and $6 a dozen at most it's a 50
cents it's 50 cents worth of learning in
that now if the kid just throws it
against the wall and and turns the other
way no then you you have a vandal on
your hands you got a vandal you're
raising a vandal if he just takes the
egg throws it against the wall he's like
Yay it's like oh yeah walks the other
way right right but if they throw it
against the wall and then analyze it let
that go okay right so point is and then
we got to wrap here so the point is the
these are experiments and as long as it
doesn't kill the child you should not
worry that it makes your home messy
because that's what that is the
consequence of a
free that's the consequence of a child
performing experiments at every turn of
curiosity that descends upon them as
long as you don't get in their way to
that they will they will become
scientists through and through their
whole lives there it is there you go so
your home is their laboratory deal with
it well oh that that sounds awful I'm
just
saying that's why kid kids who still
have diapers they play with their poop
they're experimenting this is all
fascinating texture yeah that's you know
let go let yeah don't and don't scar
them when they're playing with their
poop because that's going to lead to
some serious problems later on in life
just say
okay wait well one other there are
things experiments they might do that
could harm them right so watch out for
those that's all see those are the ones
I say let them do because they will
learn the quickest you know no it
depends if they lose fingers and stuff
or they die so but my kids were playing
in the
doorway my kids were playing in the
doorway I said let me put an end to this
right now rather than tell them don't do
that you could lose a finger I took a
pencil put it in the doorway slam the
door and the pencil snapped damn that's
gang and I showed them the two halves of
the pencil that was gangster and then I
showed them the mark in the mark in the
doorway remained there for the rest of
their lives where the pencil broke right
they they never played in a doorway
again that's yeah I would never use a
pencil either God that was that's
traumatic uh yeah yeah me I just let my
kids stick stick I let my kids stick a
fork fork in the outlet you know okay
that that'll that'll uh blow the circuit
and they'll never do that a second time
no they'll never do it again and they're
totally fine yeah they don't get
electrocuted you know like you said a
trips the circuit it pops they get blown
back it's a spark it's a spark yeah it
pops yeah it pops they they get blown
back and then they never they never do
it again in
life
wait there's an XKCD comic this is this
is the where your life splits between
will you become a scientist or not okay
so there's a wire and the person
connects the two wires and they get a
shock and they say I'll never do that
again and then the other option is you
do it and makes a shock and it shocks
you and you say I wonder if that happens
every time I do
that so the scientist is checking for
Trends in nature right exactly and
that's the difference there you go
that's great yeah it is and by the way
if I could just give it a shout out
again the book to infinity and beyond is
all about the efforts and the trials and
tribulations invested in experiments by
scientists and engineers and just
curious people trying to make
discoveries that don't always work in
the way they had imagined but the next
person that comes along now knows what
not to
do so icarus's Wings melted trying to
you know fly and we say we laugh at him
but the next person all they have to do
is say I want to try to fly too but I
know not to make my wings out of wax
right okay there you go that's how you
that's how that
works any CH that's all the time we have
for oh man okay all right good stuff
good stuff a lot of wisdom in this in
this episode yeah good questions people
like like the universe and every thanks
for bringing those questions in and at
for the low price of uh yeah you know
just $5 a month see us on patreon.com
that's that's what you get yeah and you
get you get to write in your questions
Delight to have you guys as our support
can I say that as our support group no
that's the wrong phrasing as our
support I I kind of like support group
even better
though
thanks for being our support group in
time of need all good all right Chuck
always good to have you always a
pleasure all right Neil degrass Tyson
finishing yet another episode of Star
Talk Cosmic queries as always keep
looking
[Music]
up